[Music]
how's it going guys welcome back to this
demo rpg code along and today we're just
going to be working on yet another thing
that's where we left off here we now
have the ability to add buffs so uh you
might have noticed uh there's a few
little announcements here
uh
we're kind of going for a general system
like we're trying to avoid really
specific
things that are
super
creative of our own that are set in
stone we're we're trying to allow people
to do their own thing like yeah we're
going to have a base stats but as far as
abilities go you can come up with your
own abilities and add whatever you want
you just have to stick to the system
so we're like designing a system for an
rpg we're not we're i'm trying to avoid
making an actual
game and and leave it up to
someone else because
you know if i'm making my own creative
game i'm not gonna
share that with everybody because uh
everybody would just copy the same game
and it would lose its creativity but as
far as making a system where you can
make your own things that's typically
what you need to do
for this type of stuff anyway
is make systems so that you can expand
upon it and make your game how you want
all right
so hope that makes sense also
i'm going to go as many episodes as i
can manage i'm thinking it's going to
probably get to around 20 depending on
the overall
uh
popularity and success of this series so
far i think it's doing pretty well for
my channel and for this type of video
but uh be sure to leave a like
if you're really enjoying these and
leave comments below of anything any any
tips or what you're working on i really
appreciate it really helps the series
really helps me out and uh you know
there's other ways of supporting me
monetarily if you want to if you want to
go the extra mile but uh that's not
required or anything
uh just uh
yeah i wanted to throw that all out
there okay so let's get into it so i
took a few a day off yesterday to think
about this and i started to record it
and then i realized maybe i don't want
to do equipment this way so
it took a little a little thinking
because i was looking at the stat block
and i was thinking you know we are
re-typing
this
over and over this strength intellect
armor
uh agility and like armor res uh we're
typing once here we're typing it once
here uh
anywhere we kind of have the same block
again here we got it once again here
so maybe we want this to be its own
thing and we'll overload some operators
to work on it
because yeah well this is a stat block
uh maybe we want something like a like
core stats i'm thinking uh
maybe it should be its own class but i'm
just going to put it above
stat block for now because we're going
to use this for the equipment too
because your equipment you know it's
mainly going to modify armor and element
resistance but
it could also modify strength and elect
agility if it's like magical or
something enhances your abilities after
all this is
in theory uh some sort of
template for any kind of rpg and
whatever you want to do
in general should be capable with the
stats and stuff like that uh what do we
want to call this well we already have a
stat block so we don't really want to
say that again
but i think it makes sense to say
something like core stats i like core
stats yeah i guess that works fine and
we'll just take
this and put it here
and just uh take all this base off of it
and now what we can do is we can
implement four stats but we want to
overload a few operators here too
that way we can add them together like
we could say a plus equals
so
let's see operators now operators have
the syntax of well return type we'll
change that it's
not going to be void but operator it's
plus equals
and then whatever it ends up doing
so this way we can just add two of them
together we need like a
left hand side
and a right hand side
now and it needs to be this variable
for stats
uh by reference
right hand side
and we need to return
a reference to four stats
so a little a little operator we're
gonna work on these uh operators a
little bit here and uh just keep
prepping this up now um i've i've done
this slightly wrong right but that's
fine we could just go look these up now
there's a lot of info out there on these
but you know the point is you're never
going to remember every single thing you
can do in a language you're always going
to need to look stuff up so don't be
afraid to just take a moment
and uh and look it up it's not that big
of a deal let's see here's a good one
so
uh this is kind of an old answer but it
has the most upvotes so it's pr and it
has a check mark so it probably works so
we can give it a try and let's just
observe so they got operator plus equals
and they have right hand side okay so we
don't need the left hand side the left
hand side
is assumed
already so we just go like that and it
looks like they have const because we're
not going to change the right hand side
we're changing the left hand side
there we go just get that split on this
side but as you can see yes we're
returning
uh whatever it is so their class are
struck in this case it's called num
ours is core stats
but returning by reference that way you
get
the actual thing returned
this way you can concatenate them and
get together and stuff
and then we got the operator we've got
plus equals we're also going to be doing
a plus equals 1 for when we add to the
stats and let's just put fonts here that
way they can't accidentally change the
right hand side
and we're going to say this
now we got to do this for all of them
so we're going to say like
this dot strength
plus equals right hand side dot strength
and we need to do this for everything
now this is a pointer to this class
so yeah we just need to populate these
down and just do a little
copy paste action until they're all
filled out
and then we need to return it as a
reference here so return
star this because this by default is a
pointer to the class so you need to
de-reference it so it's the actual
object and then this turns it back into
a reference
uh so that it's a reference to the class
that way we're not making copies if
you're if you're doing this sort of
thing you're going to return a copy of
the class
and it's not going to do what you expect
so you need to make sure you get that
reference in there to make sure you're
not copying the class
all right and that should take care of
it
and now
we should really should test this now
this brings up a point that i should uh
we should be building tests for all the
stuff we're doing and that's sort of
what we're doing like when we type stuff
in main and get and test it out to see
if it works that's essentially our test
but in reality what we should be doing
is
well i'm thinking we should be building
all this stuff here as our game library
as like a static library probably static
library that'd be fine in this case and
then we should have a sub project for
tests that literally just tests all the
aspects of our library and then we
should have yet another sub project that
is like the main
runner game that does everything
and
uh yeah i'm just throwing that out there
because there's probably going to be an
episode where we literally just do that
but for now we're going to stick with
our method of just
building up stuff
and testing out our new stuff in the
main because that's uh where we've been
going
and how we've been doing it
so i think this is the main operator we
need now we could do some other
operators or we could do some other
things let's look at our stat block
again
so this may this plus equals is the one
we're using most frequently
so
we're probably just going to leave it
for now
since it's the most frequent but we
could overload any of these
really
we probably want a minus equals
but
once again we we should also in here we
should be checking
that things aren't going and wrapping
to
positive or negatives in any case
especially on the negative one we want
to make sure that's not happening
so how can we do that
because well let's let's go ahead and
just copy this down
control d
uh
format this a little bit there we go
and let's just make this one a minus
equals
minus
and change all these symbols
to minus equals
oh it's uh doing it on the wrong stuff
we want to start here
okay well i guess we'll just manually
type it and i'm going to line them up so
that they're easy to modify here all at
once
um just like so
well
there we go so we want to check right
down below that
they're not wrapping to some giant
number basically and the easiest way to
check is
well you've got this right hand side and
you've got this left hand side so you
want to make sure
it is lower than whatever it previously
was lower or equal if it turns out that
it is higher
than what it was previously
you've done something wrong
that's
that's going to be the main thing and
that's that's an unsigned it so
we could just implement another one for
stats
tim
and we probably want an equals
equals this dot
uh
yeah it just equals this we'll just make
a copy of it here
so
just like so
but now we need an equals so equals
should default
to just doing exactly what you would
expect it to do
so we don't necessarily have to design
equals one it should be already
implemented for us basically at least in
this version of c plus plus and let's
see what are we on let's go to
properties here
and uh we're on 14. 14 is fine that's uh
that's a default we could go to 17 if we
wanted maybe we will later
but uh the point of getting that copy
you know that this does make this
function kind of slow
and uh not
as good
but the whole point is we can now do
some comparisons uh down below so we do
our operation
and we basically want to say
we want to do a big if here
and just compare them all in this
well we want to see if the new strength
this dot
strength if it is greater
than that temp strength
so basically if we did a minus operation
and it ended up being greater
than what it was before we know it
didn't go right we'd know that it went
below zero and wrapped to a really big
number because it's now greater so that
that's it and in those cases the only
thing we want to do
is just set it to zero so we just say
this
strength
equals
zero
on sine zero okay
so that's it we can just do that for all
of them
just to make sure
that it didn't wrap incorrectly and that
should prevent some bugs in the future
we're just going to copy all these
and we'll run a test of this here in a
second
just to see how it goes
so there we go if any of them ended up
greater than what they were previously
we are just going to set them to zero
and that should handle
all those edge cases
of that i'm just going to line these up
not something you have to do i wonder if
the auto formatting breaks this nice
lineup
yeah it does uh that's kind of annoying
um but uh we'll just we'll just deal
with it we're actually done with this
so
yeah this function looks good now we
could do a similar thing here for if it
wraps above the highest possible
unsigned end but that's like billions
you know there's uh that's not going to
happen as often so it's such a re you
know if we were doing like a real
extreme can't ever have an error we're
going to mars with this software we
probably would but that case is going to
be really rare because our numbers are
just not going to get that big in this
game so
we're going to not worry about that so
much
but now we have this core stats that we
can implement and we can do some basic
operations on it that we've been doing
except now we can shortcut it all
because we have
this all set up so let's go ahead and
just do that here
take this stat type and we'll just call
it core stats now
and we're just going to call it base
stats
and now
all these capitals
this kind of you know we're
we got a capital case here and we got
capital case here in her name and it's
going to be a little confusing so let's
camel case this one
to base stats that way we know it's uh
what kind of variable it is just by
looking at it a little more
all right and then we want to do a
similar thing
well first of all let's uh let's go
ahead and just default all these to zero
uh just with the this equals zero real
quick here
and that way they default constructs to
zero
and collapse that down and that way we
don't have to do this equal zero here
just yeah they always start at zero and
that's that's fine unless we instantiate
them otherwise and then we want to do
the same thing here
for stats
uh
total
stats
uh oh it's from buffs so we want uh
four stats
uh yeah let's do total stats
from books
there we go
lowercase that
and there we've got those now
so we've got our base stats the total
stats and we need to put them together
to get
all the stats uh so maybe
you know i don't actually like this
total word after all um stats from buffs
is clearer because i feel like when you
put total in there it somewhat implies
that it's already added the base being a
total and all so base and then stats
from buffs
and that should be good enough
also there also might be a case for like
putting the stats for buff somewhere
else so i i don't necessarily want to
undo the work we already did from last
episode so i'm going to leave it for now
but i was sort of thinking maybe we do
the adding of the buffs in the player
character rather than
in the stat block but uh
it's it's fine for now
all right so
now that core stats is public we can
we can just pop it in here as needed and
we've got some defaults here
for this one and it's now a little
confused so
ah yeah we're gonna have to do this sort
of thing oh and
and just put
dot and whatever it is like
we're just gonna have to take these
now we could default
construct it from just one of the types
with another constructor
where they have to fill out the stat
block and then they pass it in
so we're going to add that functionality
in here just for
ease of use
but as you can see these are going to
default to once
so maybe it actually makes sense to
default these two ones here
on the core stats that way
we just don't want zero to be a viable
stat starting stat so like what happens
if they have zero strength or intellect
maybe we should actually
uh say it can't go below one
uh maybe we should say it can't be zero
but
because that might mess up our
calculations like if we try to do some
multiplication with these stats in mind
if they're 0 it's just going to turn
everything into zeros
and that might not be what we want so
we're going to have to think about that
a little but for now we're just going to
go with it and we'll leave it how it is
basically
so
we'll think about that when we start
calculating more but for now i'm
thinking
it's probably fine
it's probably fine being being zero now
we have these get base do we want to
just get the whole thing at once or do
we want to
uh get
the part of it
that is relevant
so we're going to need to put
a
base
here and a dot and now we can get rid of
that word so it looks it looks pretty
similar but a little different
and
it returns a stat type
uh bass stats
you know uh we're kind the word stats is
actually a little redundant here because
it's called core stats and then base
stats just base
is clear enough in my opinion and that
will cut us
it just saves a lot of
little text there or anytime we need to
we don't want to be retyping stats and
so we already know it's a stat because
it's the core stat stat block
now that's pretty clear enough there so
that we just do that
just change these functions a little bit
i'm just going to work on lining them up
so that i can do a mass edit
something i like to do
and we should be able to just change all
this
the old alt shift select is
really handy
and yeah we'll just get these to get
these totals
and this one of course it's just base
stats from buffs
uh
stats
from
buffs
and we can shorten these up and take off
all this from buffs
here because that's now in the variable
type
or the variable name there
rather
and
there we go looking looking better
already
and now we have to modify these and get
these all straightened out
so
interesting thing going on here where
yeah we're just going to keep working on
these
methods here
so we now have an increased stats that
essentially gonna do the same thing
we can consider
changing uh you know making
just additional versions of these same
functions that take the core stats so
you can pass it
on at once we might just go ahead and do
that
but uh yeah let's go ahead and
just go
base on these
uh but you see this uses plus equals and
we overloaded that so we can do
something super special here super
awesome and just
use our plus equals
uh however
the problem is
we have all these ones individually
and uh the rest are not so
that's that's why we can't necessarily
just do it like that but let's go ahead
and make another version of this
function
uh that is useful and that way the end
user can use either and we'll have this
one bring in
core stats and what's it c
uh or maybe cs
and this one can use the plus equals
uh we'll go
base
uh plus equals cs
and that's all it needs to do
that handles everything because it
forwards to
this function right here
so that's pretty cool
that makes it pretty simple
uh so a question just recently about
object oriented programming versus data
oriented design i might make a video on
that
at some point i need to prepare a few
things but in general
what i would say is data oriented design
is where you keep your program as simple
as possible
and as
things are coming in and changing you
basically add them to lists or vectors
uh and then you end up
kind of constructing you know kind of
this system right here
is sort of reminiscent of data oriented
design
because
the end user can pass in whatever buffs
they want
and it just passes them in here
and it becomes
designed more by
data than it does by
object oriented so
that's generally what people are talking
about now this buff isn't very versatile
so usually you want something even more
versatile if you're doing that
but uh that's just all say on it for the
moment
i guess uh you know another example you
can check out my uh game engine the
public version of it it's just ancient
archer you can find it on my channel or
find it on my github
that the way
we do most of the functionality of the
engine is
based on lambdas that the end user
passes in
and they can design it however they want
and that's sort of in also a data
oriented design
except the data that you bring in is
actually
your own function so it's even more
versatile
uh yeah
that's uh probably a pretty simplistic
answer to that but we'll keep going
all right so we got that one we got that
one
now we have this recalculate buffs
oh boy this is gonna be tricky
all right we
first want to start with core stats
right here for stats
templar well well
temp
total yeah we'll just call it temp total
so we're going to name all these
and
we're going to match case on this one
because we don't want it to go find that
everywhere in our file
uh
i guess we gotta go
minus equals
on
the whatever they're bringing in right
whatever the debuff is
so these buffs now
let's look at our buffs here
uh
buffs we want to have a base to let's go
so we got to go over to buff so i'm
going to change this so this whole block
here can now just be core stats and
we'll just call it buffed
maybe buff stats i don't know
i don't really want to put the word buff
down there or stats on there again but
just uh
buff sounds like a true or false you
know
uh it's just i feel like it's more clear
in this case
to say buffed stats yeah in our in our
buff here uh or maybe we'll just call it
buffs but uh that that then sounds like
a vector of buffs or a list of buffs so
i guess buff stats is the best i'm
coming up with it here off the top of my
head uh and we'll capitalize it because
the rest is but now we need to worry
about this constructor a little bit
and how it works
because we now need to say well the
name's fine the duration's fine but the
strength
is now going to be but
stats
dot strength
and it doesn't particularly like this
so it might be because it hasn't
compiled yet we might we might not be
allowed to do it this way
with it being instructed like that so
let's just bring it down here
and we'll just say
well stats strength equals str so
whatever they pass in so we can do that
for
for all these let's just copy this down
a few times and just use the power
of copy pasta
to bring all these
down
and we'll clean it up here in a second
and there we go so that works about the
same we we might want a constructor
version that allows
uh we'll probably do this in a few other
places but
let's see these are the same
uh maybe we'll change where this is
debuff
and make it not on the end
and just make it here
before all of that
now it's going to change the ordering of
some of our other stuff
too but that's uh not too big of a deal
and why isn't it like this one
oh it's because we've got compiler
errors here and it hasn't populated down
further
so well yeah let's do the same thing
here
and uh the last part here let's just
take
an actual
uh chord stat
we'll call cs again
and on this one it's gonna be about the
same
we'll still set these just as we were
before let's break to a new line here
and now in this block of code
we can just say
we can just use the equals operator
equals cs
so it'll just equal whatever they come
in
yes uh so you know that's one of the
nice things about
these simple
structs is some of these operators are
implied like you've noticed probably
we've used the equal one in several
places yet we haven't written it it's
because it's it's implied with
the default
like there's only
four
simple types there are five simple types
in here so it it's smart enough the
compiler is smart enough to imply that
if we say
some core stat equals another one that
is just the only five variables in here
so this nice little thing we get going
on there
all right so i think we've got this
worked out now we've got a new
constructor with this type
uh oh we need to we need default
constructors on this cs as well
uh i guess does equal default work here
no it doesn't
so
that's going to be a little tricky we
need
uh i guess we do need to overload the
equals operator
to say something here
for if we pass it in like an integer or
an unsigned end
because uh it knows how to accept itself
but it doesn't know how to accept
uh some default integer so let's just do
that real quick that way we can support
that default value core stats
operator equals
const
uh we'll just say stats type and
this will just set them all to the same
thing and
yeah we'll just call it right hand side
return star this at the end
but basically all we want to do is just
set them all equal to whatever
that right hand side is
uh equals operators here
but uh now what we can do
is just going back to our
buffs here
is this will now work or it should
because this will just i guess we need
to be unsigned
otherwise it's confused
but this should uh work off that
that operator
and know what to do but we'll see if
this compiles i could be wrong maybe
this is supported in a later version or
something but this should work since we
now have it defined
now i might need to hit compile first
for that to uh really understand what's
going on there uh we're probably gonna
have some errors because i'm mid work
here
yeah we got some uh stuff here we still
need to figure out so
back in the stat block and recalculate
buffs
we just need to work on these temp
totals and all this stuff
and uh basically just do some some plus
equals okay so we've worked out
the buffs
so we just need b dot
buff stats we need to use the those
operators
on there and then we don't have to write
this all out over and over because it'll
just
defer to those
uh operators that we've defined
uh these ones here and it'll just run
these functions
so
pretty interesting stuff
very handy
what's the problem here
uh
so what if we name this we name this
something else okay
we just need to straighten this out it's
stats from buffs
okay
and maybe we don't need stats in that
variable name but
yeah let's uh let's actually take it off
lowercase that f and just call this from
box
i feel like that's pretty
pretty clear
all right now let's keep working on
these
uh this is fine we've got a new way to
increase stats by bringing in some core
stats
uh well let's see what else we have we
got
this uh this buff system and then
we got some checkers now uh
this we no longer need
well we want to take our total
uh just from
buffs
so we can do away with all that
so from buffs is just going to equal
whatever this temp total ended up being
after going through all the buffs and
debuffs
and
this here just make sure it's not below
zero
so i guess we still want that although
uh in reality with this minus equals
this should straighten it out anyway
and uh yeah it won't be able to be below
zero based on the logic of these plus or
minus that we're using so we can get rid
of all this code it's now redundant and
there you can see we have
cleaned up this recalculate buffs a lot
if we delete even a few more
lines
this is just a much cleaner function
with this core stats struct all set up
so now that this core starts to set up
yeah we may need to occasionally add a
new operator to it but overall
this is going to be some nice code that
we can just rely on
for a long time and not have to
basically do blocks like this too often
we're doing them in this case because
you know we want to be able to get them
individually
but we could even just return the whole
stats block and allow it you know and
imply that the end user
should be the one to
call the dot operator
because we could do like a
stat type or uh core stats here we could
just do a return
for stats
get stat
block
or get core stats or something you know
we could do that
instead and just return this entire
struct
but uh i like the individual ones for
now that uh
i think that's fine it's not too many
lines it's only ten lines between both
of them so it's not going to save us a
significant amount and there's a pretty
they're pretty clean functions on their
own there's not a ton going on in those
so yeah unlike this recalculate buffs it
was a giant block of code was kind of
hard to understand but now just looking
at this it's pretty simple we just get
the total of all the buffs
and uh we set it to that and that's
that's pretty easy to read now
okay at this point you know i wanted to
do equipment today
but this has been a pretty important
lesson so let's just fix all the rest of
the errors
and we'll call the day so it does it
looks like
this overloaded operator here
is just not working
it's just uh i guess you can't default
value these
with the overloaded operators
maybe there's a way to if you know leave
a comment down below or you're welcome
to fix this over on github and make a
pull request
but it seems that this default value
here doesn't work
and the thing about default values is
they do have to be
last so since we have default values on
some of these
we actually need to bring this core
stats
near the front
so if you're using this method you do
have to specify both the name and the
core stats and you can leave duration in
its debuff default
but that sort of breaks uh this one
because this one
you can leave everything
default to zeros
and just uh just give it a name
yeah i guess that works i just don't
like that they have different orders
per so i'm actually going to take all
these
and put them after name
like so
basically so that it sort of matches the
other functions
uh that's really the only reason just
break a few lines there
but yeah that uh that looks fine let's
go ahead and build this
and just uh keep addressing these errors
we got a
identifier
unknown unknown
okay so it doesn't know what core stats
are now these come in from the stat
block but as i was talking about at the
near the end of last episode the order
that you include
matters very significantly
when you're doing all headers like this
so
we have to look at our main probably
and then our player character
and see what order they're coming in
here
and really analyze that or what we can
do is we can just take this core stats
and put it in its own file
and it's going to simplify those
include
problems so we'll just do that i copied
all the code i'm going to make a header
file called
core stats
and it's just gonna be this struct
so this way
it'll build on its own we need to
include types here
that way it knows about stat type
and that should take care of this
undeclared unknown identifier problem
or at least some of them but uh no we
still have something so
we need just need to address these why
doesn't it like it
here in this buff let's see oh we need
to include it
it's sort of a no-brainer there right
we'll just include four stats before
stat block there
build again
see if it complains about anything nope
that's it
that's the only one we got a success
we do need to take a look at our main
again
uh none of these functions changed
uh we basically have just prepared
things for ease of use later so we can
hit play
everything still works
and we just
you know made some nice functionality
with these overloaded operators it's
also a great example of how and when to
use these
because as you can see here yeah we'll
probably never touch this core stats
again unless we're adding another stat
and need to add or remove from all of
them at once but in general
our stat block is just very very it's uh
it's a lot more simplified in general
it's going to be a lot easier
to continue to work with
and that's going to be really nice for
when we add in other items
and
such all right well this episode i think
is long enough
so we will end it here and uh
we'll work on more stuff in the next one
so thank you for following along and i
appreciate all you guys and all the
support
and keep coding i'll see you in the next
one peace out
[Music]
you